landlord organizations are telling
lawmakers in Washington we need help -
they say fewer of the renters are paying
rent and a to the landlord's have bills
to pay
as the coronavirus crisis enters its
third month in the u.s. more and more
tenants are protesting paying their rent
cancel right now me we are not going to
be well many people pay rent to large
corporations around half of Americans
who rents rent from individual landlords
there are about 8 million owners in this
category most of whom have between one
and ten properties
thank you for figuring out how to to do
your Skype that's nice Fidel Hussein
says her rental income is her only
income her homes are in Schenectady New
York a Riverside city of around 60,000
that's three hours north of Manhattan
for single family homes rent for on
average around $1,200 per month
I used up my savings to invest in you
know one property by big second-ranking
eventually over the years you know
accumulate a few more more than a few
you're up to 14 right now right hey
Hussein who's 61 years old and a widow
says she has so many tenants not paying
their rent right now that she can't pay
all her mortgages she says these four
homes are vacant and need repairs which
now she can't afford Hussein was in the
process she says of trying to evict the
tenants of two homes when New York
declared a 90-day moratorium on
evictions they and three other tenants
she says have yet to pay their April
rent did people lose their jobs is that
the issue well they haven't responded to
my letter asking them in the proof if
they are affected or if there are
unemployed because of the coab 819 and
when I call I'm not getting any response
either Hussein says she would work with
her tenants on payment options and
perhaps even lower their rent if she
could get a hold of them according to
records she shared with us if all the
houses she owned were rented and current
on payments she would have collected for
the month of April 6
$10,000 she only took in sixty three
hundred dollars which she says doesn't
cover her costs it's so hard I am so
confused I'm lost I'm stressed Hussein
says she hasn't been able to reach her
mortgage lenders and is trying to get a
small business loan Minnesota
congresswoman Ilhan Omar introduced a
bill that would cancel rents and
mortgages during the corona virus
pandemic we want to make sure with this
package that no one is going to be left
behind and that our system in itself
it's not going to break down but how big
is this package I read through the bill
and I didn't see dollar estimates
without taking full into full account
the scope of the problem we can't really
estimate the the amount of money it's
it's going to need the bill has a tough
road ahead with no broad bipartisan
support and critics decrying provisions
favoring renters how concerned are they
about their businesses right now they're
they're petrified they wake up every
morning very concerned about what the
future holds frankly one of the most
active advocates for landlords in New
York is the community housing
improvement program which has over 4,000
owners and managers Jay Martin is the
head of chip Martin says the government
should bear more responsibility and
suspend taxes for landlords like Hussein
governments are not willing to entertain
the idea of suspending taxes because
they're also in financial hardship right
now many of our municipalities across
this country rely on these property
taxes to be able to sustain their
communities so we want to make sure that
landlords have the resources that they
need in order to still fulfill their
obligations so if you're what happens if
your bill doesn't pass nothing is done
that will be a complete devastation we
are looking at like I said a huge
collapse of house our housing market if
this continues what are you gonna do I'm
just gonna have to stop making all the
payments on these
even the insurance if something happened
I don't know what's gonna happen you
stop because there's no money is the
money if may and the summer months are
as bad for her as April was Hussein says
she'll have to let some of her
properties go or I decide if I wanna
continue being an online or I just want
to get out I don't think I can keep
handle I can't handle it anymore I can't